He grew up to be over six feet tall,
the fashionable dresser and friends with some of the most famous Americans of
his time,
but he started his life in a corner of the Austrian empire.
In today's video,
we're talking about the great Nikola Tesla.
When Nikola Tesla was born,
the Austrian empire,
it's still existed and ethnic sir.
He came into the wells in modern day Croatia on July the 10th 1856 his birth
seem to foreshadow his life's work as his mother was in labor during a massive
lightning storm.
The lightening,
the flash during Tesla's birth,
who was considered to be an ill omen by the midwife,
but Tesla,
his mother didn't greed.
Instead,
she proclaims that he will be a child of light.
His mother was not wrong.
As we know today,
Tesla is the reason we have alternating current electricity,
but on top of that,
starting in childhood,
Tesla saw flashes of light that reportedly canes him before he had ideas.
There is another side to the story of these flashes of light that has emerged.
However,
it's possible that these flashes or visions were actually caused by a traumatic
events that he witnessed in his childhood.
When destiny was just five years old,
he saw his only brother Dane die in a horse riding accidents.
It was after this that Tesla began having the flashes of light and his visions.
These were something that would stay with him for the rest of his life.
The family,
they lived in a modest home,
one that has since been rebuilt and has a statue of Tesla in the yard.
That's when his father was an eastern Orthodox minister and his mother was a
brilliant woman who was an inventor herself.
She created mechanical appliances to use around the house and to tinkering and
creative thinking.
Undoubtedly influenced her son,
tested his mother also has an incredible memory.
She could memorize entire epic poems and Tesla credited his own photographic
memory to the genes that he inherited from his mother.
He memorized entire books.
He visualized his projects and ideas and he spoke several languages and his
other years at school,
Tesla studies focused on German,
maths and religion.
By the time he entered the later years of his education,
signs had become a key focus.
He moved away from his family in order to do attends the higher real gymnasium
here.
Tesla was accused of cheating because of his photographic memory.
His outstanding memory allows him to perform integral calculus using only as
minds.
No panel paper was required and this led his teachers to become suspicious.
Nonetheless,
Tusla was able to finish the necessary work,
actually graduate in only three years instead of the customary four.
During his three years at the high real gymnasium,
Testa was introduced to a phenomenon that ultimately defined his career and how
he's remembered today and his physics class.
The teacher demonstrated electricity and Tesla was utterly fascinated by it,
but it would be some time before he could launch a career studying and using
electricity.
He became ill shortly after graduating in 1873 for nine months he was bedridden
with color and only narrowly escaped his brush with death helped form Tesla is
lifelong Germaphobic tendencies.
He was so fearful of jams that it took him 18 napkins to get through a single
meal.
In 1874 Tesla was expected to be conscripted into the military and he had no
interest in serving so he managed to escape the requirements by running away to
a mountainous region where he was able to disguise himself as a hunter.
After a year,
Tesla was able to emerge from the mountains and start seriously studying
science.
He began attending classes at Austria pall attack and Eric,
who very quickly showed himself to be both a talented and diligent students.
In fact,
he may actually have been a little too diligence years after he left the school
and after his father had died,
Tesla discovered a pile of letters that the school sent to his father,
warning them that Tesla was overworking himself.
According to Tesla himself,
he was working incredibly hard getting up at 3:00 AM and not going to bed until
11:00 PM during that time,
he was fully focused on his studies.
He didn't even take off holidays or Sundays from this routine.
By the time his first year was over.
He had passed it twice as many exams as he needed to and received the highest
grades that were possible,
but even someone with a brain like Tesla's couldn't sustain that kind of
schedule.
His second year in school was a complete reversal from his first after losing a
scholarship.
At the end of his second year at Tesla,
began gambling,
gambling.
It wasn't just a pastime for him,
though he was totally addicted to us.
He lost his tuition,
money,
gambling,
and then when final exams rolled around,
he was unprepared to take them.
Indeed,
you never did take them and he never graduated.
Unwilling to face his family and tell them that he never graduated.
Tesla simply fled to the town of Meribah and took up work as a draftsman.
It was here that he started gambling again,
playing cards on the street.
At first,
some of Tesla's friends thought that he had drowned,
but Tesla's father figured out the truth.
Eventually he tried to get his son to return home at Tesla.
He adamantly refused.
Eventually he was forced to,
or a town home when he was arrested for not having a resident's permit for yet.
Tesla worked as a teacher in Gospick for town.
Rose family lived,
but his extended family,
they wanted to help him get back to school so they pooled their funds and off to
Prague he went,
but it wasn't an easy jump back into academia.
He arrived too late.
Do you actually enrolled and even if he hadn't been late,
Tesla was missing some of the key studies required to enroll.
Namely these were check and Greek.
So Tesla once again,
did not achieve as academic dreams bars.
By 1881 he was able to find work in his preferred field.
He had found a job as an electrical engineer with a central telephone company in
Budapest.
While working there,
he and a friend had a habit of walking through the park one day during the walk.
Tesla,
I've got one of his visions.
He knew how to bills and induction motor.
He picked up a stick,
found a patch of dirt and sketched out his idea that,
and then he then went on to build a prototype of this motor.
It made sense to him and he knew the importance of it,
but he couldn't drum up much interest for his invention in Europe.
Wow.
Tesla was working in Europe.
Thomas Edison had launched his Edison Company,
which included a branch in Paris,
Tesla.
It secured a job at the Continental Edison company helping with the installation
of lighting in Paris.
His talents were soon taken advantage of for design and for trouble shooting.
Within two years,
he was recruited to travel to America and his work for Edison directly in New
York.
He ends hundreds of others who worked in Manhattan installing lights and
building out in electric utility for New York City.
Tesla described his experiences and impressions of Edison.
Thusly I came from bearers in the spring of 1880 forum was brought in intimate
contact with him.
Thomas Edison.
We experiments it day and night.
His existence was made up of ultimate periods of work and sleep and the
laboratory.
He had no Hobie cat for no sport or amusements of any kinds and lived in utter
disregard of the most elementary rules of hygiene.
That can be no doubt that if he had not married later,
a woman of exceptional intelligence who made it to the one object of her life to
preserve him,
he would have died many years ago from consequences of sheer neglect.
So great and uncontrollable was his passion for work,
but as he has in his first year of school,
Tessa was also a nonstop worker.
One story,
it relates that he stayed out all night working and took some jobs from people
for being out all night.
When Edison found out he was actually out working Tesla and Addison's respect
working for Edison,
it wasn't ideal for Tesla,
like he only lost it six months at the company.
Edison and Tesla disagreed over alternating current and direct current with
Tesla at favoring alternating currents and Edison favoring direct,
but it's still unclear if this disagreement was the primary reason why Tesla
ended up leaving the company.
Tesla and Edison also differed in their approaches to business and science.
Addison was attuned.
Stevie marketing side of things.
While Tesla was highly focused on the scientific invention and innovation part
of its work,
it's possible his leaving may have been precipitated by a bonus that he thought
he was guessing,
which he was later refused.
A manager at the Edison company had challenged employees to design it to
different machines.
The first person to successfully do so would receive a huge bonus $50,000 which
translates to millions of dollars by today's standards.
Desola jumped at the chance to tackle this invention and a huge amount of money.
He completed the task,
presented his work and was denied the bonus.
The manager and Edison claimed that the challenge had been issued jokingly and
Addison himself told and upset Tesla,
Tesla,
you don't understand our American humor regardless of the reason.
The fact is that tests the departed from Edison's company only after a few short
months,
he had his in his mind that he was going to start his own company where he would
research and work with alternating current.
It wasn't so easy to get assaulted.
They went tests,
liquid Edison's company.
He had to earn money to live on like digging ditches for only $2 a day.
My High Education in various branches of science and mechanics and literature
seemed to me like a mockery.
He said if this time while he was doing that though he was pitching investors,
he founds people who liked what they heard and trusted the scientific knowledge
of this young immigrants.
By 1895 he was working on getting his art lighting system patenters and had a
funding promise from two businessmen to start Tesla electric lights and
manufacturing or any of the year into the venture though they pulled out and
left Tesla in the lurch.
Yes.
Again,
the inventor was penniless.
In 1886 he met two men who were looking to invest in scientific inventions.
They sent us the rub with a laboratory in New York City,
established a profit sharing structure and the Tesla Electric Company was born
in only a year.
Tesla had created an induction motor that ran on alternating currents.
This time he had two business partners who weren't ready and willing to handle
the marketing and business end of things.
Soon after Tesla published a paper in entitled a new system of alternating
current motors and transformers.
It laid out his ideas and to got him noticed George Westinghouse as one of the
people who read the paper and he liked what he read,
Westinghouse licensed Tesla's induction motor and also gave him a consulting job
at the Westinghouse electric and manufacturing lab in Pittsburgh.
Westinghouse wanted to be the person who provided the United States with long
distance power and he believed Tesla was the person who is going to help him
achieve that goal.
In the early 1890s Westinghouse and Edison were competing heavily in the
electric industry.
Edison was throwing out claims that tested as AC current wasn't safe,
and meanwhile Westinghouse was facing financial difficulties,
but Westinghouse paid Tesla for the licensing and so he had the ability to
continue working on projects that he wanted to one of these projects,
you might actually have heard of it,
that would be a Tesla coil.
The Tesla Coil,
which he passengers in 1891 allows electricity to be transmitted wirelessly.
It was the first invention of its kind and it was used in antennas that we used
to send telegraphs and even though the original design isn't used anymore,
a different version of this is still used in TV and radio to this very day.
1891 was also another landmark and testers life for it was the year that he was
granted us citizenship.
Tesla continued his relationship with Westinghouse into the 1890s as they sought
his help for the 1893 Columbian Exposition in Chicago.
Westinghouse was in charge of lighting the entire events but also had their own
display that here he gave demonstrations to the public showing how a AC current
works.
Eh,
Tesla is next major project.
It came at Niagara Falls.
Power was being generated by the false,
but there wasn't need for an efficient transmission system based on Tesla's
recommendation.
Westinghouse was hard to build an AC generation system at Niagara.
Tesla did the design work and the resulting to hydroelectric power plants began
providing electricity to the city of Buffalo,
New York.
With all of these projects.
Tesla was gaining visibility both in America and the rest of the worlds.
He was also getting to know many high profile people and not all of them were in
the scientific sphere.
One of the American celebrities that Tesla got to know was Mark Twain.
Even when he was living in Croatia,
Tesla was reading Twain's books.
The two Matt in New York City haven't crossed paths at a social events.
Twain had always been interested in technological innovation,
so the two spends much time together in Teslas lab,
a photograph of twins hands that Tesla took using light from crooks tubes
brought to Tesla right to the edge of discovering x rays.
Unfortunately though he didn't realize quite how close he had come until x rays
were actually discovered and the use of crooks tubes in the invention was made
known.
There's,
there's not the only experiment that twain was a part of.
Though.
There was also an experiment that was specifically designed to address Twain's
digestive issues.
Drain was often constipated and he wasn't shy about complaining of this
condition.
Tesla had developed a vibrating disc that would essentially shake whoever's
stood on top of it.
Here it's author friend to climb on board the device and literally have his
digestion issues solved by shaking his bowels a loose.
When Tesla thought that's way in herds,
add enough of the shaking treatments.
He told him to get off,
but well twain,
he didn't.
Once he get off,
he stayed on top of the desk and was continued to be shaken.
Ignoring Tesla's urgings,
he should not have ignored.
Tesla's urgings there because eventually the shaking did its job and then some.
The famous author,
quite literally a went to the bathroom in his suit in the middle of Nikola Tesla
is laboratory Tesla and never stopped inventing.
He said that he only slept two hours per night and was always looking for the
next projects.
Wireless transmission of electricity was one of his main goals,
but he needed funding to achieve this.
Living in New York,
he had ample access to wealthy people.
He was able to convince j Pierpont Morgan of the viability of wireless
transmission,
and the banker provided him with $150,000 to build a transmission tower.
He was competing with Marconi to transmit wireless messages,
but Marconi got their first investors,
including Morgan,
pulled their funds from testing this project and he was forced to abandon the
effort.
In 1906 when the project was abandoned,
Tesla didn't just have to stop construction.
He actually had to mortgage the property Tesla,
and he owed huge amounts of money to the Waldorf Astoria.
He lived at the lavish hotel and he lived large spending $20,000 which is nearly
half a million dollars today.
In the short time he lived there in 1917 the transmission tower,
it was demolished after Tesla lost it in foreclosure.
They also tried to see Marconi asserting that he had stolen Tesla's ideas in
order to create his wireless transmission technology.
Eh,
Tesla was a genius.
There's no doubt about it,
but he was also a difficult man.
He had many quirks and obsessions and was completely,
utterly focused on his work.
He never married thinking that a woman in his life would interfere with his
work.
As he said,
I do not think you can name many great inventions that have been by married men,
but there are also indications that Tesla perhaps didn't think he was worthy of
women.
He also became dissatisfied with the attitude of modern women.
In the 1920s in the 1924 interview,
Tesla explained his thoughts on women.
I had always thought of women as possessing those delicate qualities of mind and
soul that made her in these respects far superior to man.
I had put her on a lofty pedestal.
I worshiped at the feet of the creature ride raised to this height,
hands like every three worshiper.
I felt myself unworthy of the object of my worship.
There's all this was in the past now,
the soft voice,
Gentle Woman of my reverent worship has all but vanished in our place,
has come.
The woman who thinks that her chief success in life lies in making herself as
much as possible like Nan in dress,
voice and actions in sports and achievements of every kind.
It's Tesla,
put some of his social ends nurturing energy that he wasn't putting towards
women towards the pigeons that flops around in New York City and it's one pigeon
in particular caught his attention.
I've been feeding pigeons,
thousands of them for years,
but there was one,
a beautiful bird,
pure white with light gray tips on its wings.
That one was different.
It was a female.
I had only two wishes and call her and she would come flying to me.
I love that pigeon as man loves a woman and she loved me as long as I had her.
That was purpose to my life.
When that pigeon was hurt,
Tesla invented a device that would help here let's swing and leg,
right.
Hmm.
Tesla lived out the rest of his life in New York City.
He never married,
but he did surround himself with the famous and intellectual people of the day
invented constantly right up through the 1930s until he was well in his
seventies in January,
1943 and they decided to enter Tesla's hotel room even though he had put up a do
not disturb sign.
This sign had been in place for 48 hours,
and when the maid opened the door,
she was confronted with the site of the famous inventors body.
He died of coronary thrombosis at the age of 86 behind in Tesla,
half day legacy of invention,
innovation,
and scientific exploration.
He played a crucial role in the spread of electricity and to the creation of
devices that led to the technologies that we all have today.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and do not forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this every day of the week.
Also,
check out some of our videos from the archives over there on the right and as
always,
thank you for watching.